like
guys like yourself guys like primo i
wish that there was more
of records like the record you did with
dizza i wish that there was
more like i like i i can't tell you how
excited i was
when you did the joy with
with with yay when you were in that
pocket where yay was doing
the good friday records and you were
working with kanye yeah
um i was just so excited because i'm
like this is what i want to hear
pete rock and kanye why didn't it happen
sooner you know what i mean yeah i know
it would have but you know like i look
at it like
you can just set it down right there
thank you thank you i look at it like
you know
like he's from my school and that was
bound to happen regardless you know what
i'm saying
talk about that era um where you were
tapping in with yay and and
the joys those are my two favorite kanye
verses
probably ever um thank you when he said
uh the the holy trinity a bad [ __ ] and
a bag or
some hennessy in the mirrors where i see
my only enemy
yo let me tell y'all something about
kanye on the lyric tip
homeboy is nice he's super nice
right right take that i will not never
take that away from him
and he's very talented you know nah for
sure man
um was there any records you did with
yay that we didn't hear
yeah i did i laid about eight beats but
i think he might have went in on more
than just one
right but i i never heard it
and i doubt if he's using anything but
you know what i mean
that's fair hey uh when you worked with
uh with yay on the joy were you
were you in was that when you did you go
to hawaii for that yes i did
what was that what was that what was
that trip like what was it like being
out there working on history because
obviously
that ended up on watch the throne but um
you know that was
my beautiful dark twist of fantasy you
know uh sessions
yep yep yep and um it was great
i mean [ __ ] that dude is living like a
prince
you know um at least on the hawaii side
i've been to
his malibu but did i was that in his
mouth no no that was russell
um the comedian i went to hang out
russell peters
yes in malibu and he told me who lives
around him and near him and i think
jay-z lived down the street and
kanye lived over there and so so forth
but anyway we was in hawaii
and had a huge
you know it was it was great that i
hadn't had fun
yeah it was crazy because at that time
he brought rizza into the fold
he brought you into the fold and it was
like
finally like these this is the people we
want to see kanye work with these are
the people who inspired him like i
played i laid eight beats
i made eight eight of my own beats you
know what i'm saying and
and we narrowed it down to one
right you know what i'm saying that's
crazy
yes but i mean you know i had so much
fun i meant
that was my first time meeting rick
rosay
rick brook i mean rose you know what i'm
saying um
i met kit cutty
that day yeah i met john legend and his
wife that day
wow yeah and then while we were working
all day and then kanye had these
little pieces of paper up all over the
studio saying no twitter
no twitter that tells you how
how long ago it was because that would
be no instagram yeah i remember he
did something like that online where he
talked about you know
and then when i went over there and was
in the studio you know
he had it all over the studio were you
hey
you were you there to witness rick ross
laying down his verse for devil in a new
dress
no i didn't i didn't see that go down
because that's one of my favorite verses